it's time for the deep dive number five
McDonald's is sharing the love the
company aired it's Super Bowl commercial
that promotes a new form of payment for
burgers and fries the currency of
l.o.v.e add in the ad customers are
caught up told to call loved one instead
of handling over cash for a meal dial up
your mom tell your lover starting today
for the next two weeks you two could be
randomly chosen to perform an act of
love and the promotion comes just days
after McDonald's announced a CEO change
amid slumping sales still with me both
Peabody venture partnered at great great
cost partners I'm going to the dance
yeah sure sounds like you're gonna be
able to do a lot of different things to
get a hamburger okay so what do you
think about this uh I you know I I
wonder if is it connected to Don
Thompson being fired well this was this
it was this his last great idea I've
been obviously in the works for months
and months before yeah obviously I I
don't you know I don't know it seems
like they're trying something which is
good right the problem is the food
quality you know the food awareness now
in in it's just unbelievable the public
in organic at Walmart you know I just
don't know if they can get past that at
the end of the day too is McDonald's too
big of a company you're talking with
Alibaba
when you have over a hundred products
you have thirty six thousand stores all
over the world's most of them franchisee
operated it's just too hard there's a
lot of other companies that are doing
that Starbucks is doing its subway is
doing it franchising on their own by the
company yeah I don't think it's a matter
of how big the company is I you know
look I think it is a matter of the food
quality you know it's just the world is
going in a different direction than
McDonald's and they have to change and
it's gonna be difficult and they have to
do a product by product they can't do it
wholesale obviously it's gonna be a very
difficult thing for them to do to fight
against the cultural shift to higher
quality food do you think though that
things like okay this ad but also say
mobile will be able to help them I mean
mobile payments say for Starbucks have
been huge right I mean can McDonald's
benefit in the same kind of way you know
I don't know if the demographic of the
McDonald's customer I don't know if
they're gonna be an early adopter to a
lot of the
platforms so I think they'll struggle
there I don't think that alone is going
to save them I can get comes down to the
product and talking about product you
know when we look at the I can't deny
that on this table yes I know bit Oreo
cookies basically we're talking about
our promotions going into Valentine's
Day for old-school products like Oreos
like McDonald's that hope that you will
buy them and do you believe in these
kind of promotions this obviously goes
against my macro trend of higher food
quality
I think these old brands they are
interesting to people and I think it's I
think you can bring them back and you
can get a lot of mileage out of these
old brands around these around these
holidays and new product launches so I
think it's again it's a good try well
which kind of brings me to the day two
of the Super Bowl ads right okay so you
have your good ad people are talking
about on Twitter you did your social
media outreach then today you got to
deliver how important is it that I walk
into a store and want to buy a Budweiser
or I want to go buy something else that
was advertised I know I I think
obviously Super Bowl ads are really
about getting into the cub consciousness
of the consumer so that it lasts for a
long time and makes an impression I
don't you know I don't know if they
measure the impact day to I think for
some of the online products use there
was so much video game advertising it
was amazing to me the number of mobile
games that were advertised I think that
is where you will see real day to impact
and you'll have to measure it but on
something like you know Budweiser that's
just that's something that they're just
trying to get into people's subconscious
so you know for years and years the
brand will grow what about the power of
say social media
remember the dunk in the dark in 2013
that was free I mean no one spent four
million dollars on that ad yet these
guys are spending four-and-a-half
million I mean is the big time Superbowl
money gonna be dead I don't think so I
still think it's one you know TV is
still growing and I think the reason
it's growing is it is TV advertising is
still growing and I think the reason
it's growing is because it's the only
place you can really tell a story about
your brand it's very hard to do that
online as we get video advertising
online obviously that gets easier but
television getting in front of that many
people and being getting 30 seconds of
their attention to tell a story about
your brand it's the only place you can
do it and
you still invest you know in small
companies that you hope will be bought
by bigger concepts are you noticing that
larger company is increasingly having a
difficult time to grow they can't find
that organic growth they really have to
be do and not only that but they have to
buy innovation you know we're seeing a
lot of companies you know paying high
multiples just for technology just for
innovations if the talent or is it the
actual equipment I think it's I think
it's it's more so the talent and and and
and the intellectual property that that
town has created I think it's not
necessarily equipment and the stuff that
we invest in but yeah they have to buy
innovation they have to buy growth you
see some of the buying growth it's hard
you know we don't invest in companies
that typically generate a lot of eBay da
you know they're generating fast revenue
growth with very good products we're
gonna talk to one today you know Nick
Tarantino from plated you know they're
yeah exactly we are an investor they
have an amazing product that is going
with the macro culture of food and
there's a lot of companies big companies
that are interested in what they're
doing and that's oh no I'm gonna make
you do these nasty looking red velvet
Oreos there you go
I have to try it I was gonna take a bite
I'm gonna take one to Bernie on the way
to break all right boys you're sticking
with me all right well coming up it's
it's just boom cheese frosting doesn't
say cream cheese it's amazing what they
can do